is it solely the man responsible for
getting the woman pregnant or does it
take two people I think it's the guy yes
because I feel that when I rub against a
woman I don't get pregnant so when you
rub against a woman we need the will of
God
yeah like for people for women I won't
get pregnant but for people for men I
will get pregnant and I feel that it is
your responsibility to make sure that
that doesn't happen because I feel like
it's Society just naturally feels like
it's our responsibility to make sure
we're on iuds bring the condoms and
things like that so yeah so wouldn't it
be more the woman's responsibility that
she doesn't get pregnant since we have
the option to get an IUD and birth
control and an abortion no